quatre chouettes de l'oral de l'espace
rambouillet ont pris la route lundi 14
juin
direction l'allemagne où elles vont
progressivement retrouver leur liberté
dans le cadre d'un programme de
renforcement de population dans le
milieu naturel en direction de
l'allemagne de la bavière où elles
seront placées dans une volière en plein
de forêt aménagée spécialement pour ces
jeunes chouettes de l'oural elles vont y
passer deux à trois semaines
d'autant qu'à s'acclimatent et ensuite
une grande porte soit ouverte
cette volière elles pourront sortir tous
les jours rentrée jusqu'à un moment
donné où elles vont prendre leur
indépendance
c'est une première pour l'espace
rambouillet qui n'avaient pas encore pu
participer à ce programme puisque seuls
les jeunes individus peuvent être
réintégrés le programme a été mis en
place depuis trois ans par les allemands
moi qu'il ya différents parcs
zoologiques en france et en europe qui
alimente ce programme avec des jeunes
nés en captivité et nous c'est la
première année qu'on a quatre bébés qui
vont pouvoir partir l'an dernier l'an
dernier il ya deux ans donc on n'a pas
eu de jeunes donc on pouvait pas
participer à cette année on a eu
beaucoup de chance
le soignant est confiant pour cette
réintroduction les chouettes n'ont pas
été élevés par la main humaine mais par
leurs parents elle le rechercherons pas
l'homme quand elles retrouveront leur
liberté
sa volée elles savent le faire il ya
aucun souci après avoir à prendre la
prédation
quand les habitants qui avoue rester
dans cette volière
les allemands qui se tuent mais c'est
désormais des sourires ils ont tué des
petits campagnols vivant mais quatre
chouettes de l'espace rambouillet seront
relâchés début juillet elles
continueront à être nourris dans leur
volière le temps qu'elles prennent leur
indépendance